there is morning in great britain
prince's britain's prince philip
died today queen elizabeth's husband was
just months away from his 100th birthday
ian lee reports from windsor england
signs of a nation in mourning the flag
at buckingham palace flies at half-staff
the news of prince philip's death posted
at the gates
the 99 year old royal passed away
peacefully this morning
at windsor castle prince philip earned
the affection
of generations here in the united
kingdom
across the commonwealth and around the
world
prince philip also known as the duke of
edinburgh was last seen in public a few
weeks ago
after he spent a month in the hospital
for an infection and a heart condition
he was the longest royal consort in
british history and was at queen
elizabeth side for more than seven
decades historians say the prince will
be remembered for both his charm
and at times controversial comments he
was
probably the most good-looking royal in
history but at the same time
he had his opinions he knew what he was
thinking he
was never easily swayed and so she could
depend on him in a way that
no one else could people are already
laying flowers here
at windsor castle this is where prince
philip spent
much of the pandemic with the queen he
was one of the best royals if i'm honest
you know i mean kind of thing kind of
you know
had a great character charisma the greek
born aristocrat who served in world war
ii retired from public engagements
several years ago
he carried out more than 20 thousand of
them on behalf
of the crown ian lee cbs news windsor
england because of chronovirus
restrictions royal officials say prince
philip will not have a public state
funeral
instead a ceremony will be held at saint
george's chapel at windsor castle